[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHN MURRAY: Welcome,
everybody, to Take
Control of your Multi-cluster,
Multi-Tenant Kubernetes
Workloads.
This is a talk we're
going to give today
about dealing with Kubernetes
in Enterprise deployments
where you've got lots of
clusters, lots of tenants.
And in particular, we're going
to talk about the GKE Policy
Management alpha that
we announced here today.
And then we'll be
demoing that in the end.
My name is John Murray.
I'm a product manager
with Google Cloud.
With me is going
to be Ray Colline,
who's one of the lead
engineers on the project.
So upfront, we're going to go
through some of the principles
that we were looking
at when we're
trying to deal with
some of the problems
around managing multiple
Kubernetes clusters
and dealing with the
multi-tenancy issues that arise
from that when you're thinking
about policies, access
control, quota limitations,
and those sorts of things.
So we'll walk through that.
Ray will spend some time
walking through the architecture
and some of the
features that we have
that we're debuting
here in the alpha.
And then we'll do a
demo for you at the end.
So to start it off, I want to
talk about, just generally,
the problems that we see
when we talk to customers
who are really looking to scale
up their Kubernetes deployment.
And these are
administrative problems.
They're the problems
of operators
in dealing with, how do you get
a bunch of development teams
onto Kubernetes infrastructure?
How do you make them
productive while ensuring
that things are secure and that
you're keeping an eye on all
of the administrative things?
So when people start
out with Kubernetes,
this is usually what we see.
These sort of cluster per
tenant scenarios, where
you have one tenant,
in this case, a dev
team, the blue
team, and they want
to play around with
Kubernetes, they
want to experiment with it, so
they go and spin-up a cluster.
And that's very easy on
GKE, but it's also very easy
to spin it up using some tooling
or to work with any other cloud
provider.
And once you have multiple
people doing this,
now you have a number of these
cluster per tenant scenarios
within your company.
So you have one tenant,
they have their own cluster,
they start running their pods
in the default namespace,
and that's fine.
They have isolation,
because that cluster
is the boundary for them,
and it's not necessarily
an administrative hassle.
But if this scales,
and you've got
100 of these clusters running
with 100 different tenants,
all running their
clusters different ways,
then it's hard to think about
normalizing things like access
control across them.
It's hard to deal with upgrades.
It's hard to deal
with versioning.
It's hard to deal with all the
sorts of administrative tasks
that you have to manage.
So the next phase
of the evolution
that we see people go through
is that they take that tenant
and they provision
them a namespace
across multiple clusters.
And so now you've got, say,
three clusters running.
Maybe you're doing that
because you need clusters
in each region close to where
your users or your workloads
are.
Maybe you're doing
it for redundancy.
There's a number
of reasons why you
might want multiple clusters.
If we give a namespace
to the blue team
in each one of
those clusters, then
they can run their pods there.
And we can attach policies, and
access control, quota control,
network policies, et
cetera, at the namespace
or at the cluster levels
to kind of normalize that.
Where it really gets tricky is
when you have multiple tenants
across multiple clusters.
So in this case, I've got
two tenants, a blue team
and a green team, each
with their own namespace
in all my clusters.
But in a real life
scenario, you may
have hundreds of
these tenant teams,
each with their own
namespace, and you may
have dozens of these clusters.
And so the scalability
problem becomes, then,
how do you manage the
policies across all of these?
Because each of these
Kubernetes clusters
is somewhat of an
island when you're
talking about
policy management--
setting up the
namespace definitions,
setting up role-based
access controls for each
of these namespaces,
and ensuring
that each of the namespaces
looks the same across all
the clusters so that your
development teams don't
have to deal with variance
across that workspace.
And today, people are managing
that in a number of ways,
but it's a lot.
And so we see it over and
over again, as people scale up
from experimenting
through Kubernetes
to dealing with it at
scale, this is a point
that they end up with.
And maybe they try to
manage it with scripts,
maybe they build
their own tooling,
but it's something that we
wanted to take a look at
and say, can we,
as Google, come up
with something for the
Kubernetes community
that helps deal with
this particular problem?
So that's where we're going to
talk about with you guys today.
Before we get into the
nitty gritty of the details
about what we've built and
what we're doing in the alpha,
I just wanted to talk about it
a couple of design principles
that we used when we
were looking through how
to deal with this problem.
So the first one is that we
didn't want Kubernetes clusters
to be islands.
Right now there's very
little federation support
in Kubernetes.
And so if you're running
dozens of clusters,
you're often interacting
with them one by one,
loading them all up into
the context of your kubectl,
and switching around,
scripting against that.
But automation here
is really the only way
to manage this in a sane way
across a lot of clusters.
So we wanted to
build tooling that
works in this
cross-cluster environment
and provides some
centralization so
that you don't repeat
yourself over and over again
when applying policies.
The other thing we
wanted to do was
create a clear separation
between infrastructure
and tenancy.
So the analogy here is
like an apartment building.
You start with an empty
apartment building
like an empty cluster,
and you need to set it up
that you can bring
people in and have
them move into the apartments.
And that's things
like setting up
the infrastructure--
the plumbing,
the heating, the electricity.
But it's also setting
up a lease, right?
What are the terms
of your tenancy?
What are you allowed to do?
You're not allowed to play death
metal at 2:00 in the morning.
You're not allowed to hang
out naked in the hallways.
You need to be a good tenant.
But within the constraints
of your apartment,
you're allowed to do
whatever you want.
You can hang up whatever
posters you want.
We're not going to tell you
what couch color you need to do.
We create a safe
environment for you
where things are
clearly delineated.
The administrative things
are for administrators,
and dev teams are freed
up to do what they
need to do in an agile way.
And the last principle
is policy workflow.
So we can automate
policies, we can centralize
policy management,
but we want to make
the actual application of
those policies easy to manage.
And oftentimes, when you're
talking about scaled up
infrastructure,
you've got a team
of people who are doing
administrative stuff setting
policies.
And so we wanted
to build workflow
around the changes that
happen around the definition
of those policies, so that
administrators could cooperate
with one another,
review policy changes,
think about policy
changes in the same way
that you think about code.
You can roll them back.
You can do reviews.
You can edit them, and have
auditability around changes
that are made there--
a lot of the things
that we take for
granted when we're talking
about source control.
We wanted to bring some of that
goodness to policy management.
So those things we
are thinking about
as we were looking at
building something.
We spent the last couple of
months here getting it ready
and bringing it out to alpha.
So please welcome to the stage
Ray Colline, my colleague.
He's an engineer on
the project, and he's
going to walk you through
Kubernetes Policy Management.
RAY COLLINE: Thanks.
Thank you, John.
And again, I'm Ray
Colline, and I'm
a software engineer who
thinks a lot about policy
management on Kubernetes.
So today we're going to actually
be getting in to talk about,
what did we do for this alpha?
And what are we going to be
doing going forward with this?
And where do we see it going?
And how, hopefully,
it can help you.
So the first thing
I want to say is
that this is just one part
of a much bigger story
that we've presented
here at Next.
And importantly, with
the hybrid story,
you'll see here that policy
management, which is down
at the bottom, fits into
the overall on-prem, GKE,
managed Istio.
We want to have a way of
dealing with all these things
from a policy perspective,
or as the analogy
that John used, thinking
about the building owner
in this case who's
trying to lease out
these apartments which have all
of these particular features.
So when we think about policy
management specifically,
we're thinking about
centrally defined policies
in a source of truth.
So you want one place
to go look at that you
can say, here is all of the
tenants in my environment
across all of my
clusters, and know that
when you submit and put
changes in that source of truth
that it applies across
all of your clusters.
And so we're really
doubling down
as namespaces in Kubernetes
as the minimum level
of tenancy for defining this.
And you can think
about it in terms
of the analogy is that
namespaces are really
those apartments that
you're leasing out.
And so with this
central policy store,
you can manage things like RBAC,
and quota policy, and more.
And that more is coming.
So I mentioned the idea
of sources of truth.
What I'm going to
try to do now is
detail how the components of
GKE Policy Management work,
and the concepts that
we've introduced.
So it starts with
the idea of a source
of truth, which is
that place where
your policies are defined.
Now, in the alpha,
I'm going to talk
about two particular sources
of truth that we support today,
but the intention is
to be able to build
arbitrary sources of truth to
meet customers where they are.
And we know a lot
of our customers
end up creating their
own policy stores,
and they want to figure
out how to make that work
with their hybrid environments.
And so, we've designed
that with this in mind,
where one's going to be able
to write a component to read
arbitrary sources of truth.
And so what we've enabled
in the source of truth
is the concept of hierarchy.
So now, today in Kubernetes,
namespaces are flat
and then there's a
cluster on top of it.
And you can basically
set a cluster-wide policy
or you can set a per
namespace policy.
But in many
organizations, they want
to actually group namespaces
and then apply policies
to a subset of namespaces.
So in GKE Policy Management
we support the concept
of a group of namespaces that
have common RBAC policies
and common quota policies.
So we have that as
the source of truth.
And then within each cluster--
so every cluster that's
being managed by GKE policy
management, there's a set of
components and controllers
that we install as part of
GKE Policy Management install.
So I'm going to first talk about
the idea of a policy importer.
And so what the policy
importer is responsible
for is reaching out to
that source of truth,
whether it be Git,
whether it be GCP,
whether it be a MySQL database,
and reading the policy data
and putting it into the
cluster as a set of CRDs,
or Kubernetes,
basically, objects
that represent the data.
And then there's the
syncer component,
which reads those and is able
to talk to the Kubernetes API
server to create those objects.
So we would manage things
like namespaces, RBAC policy,
resource quota objects,
possibly limit ranges--
there's a bunch of objects.
And the idea of that separation
is that the policy importer
knows how to speak to
different sources of truth
and normalizes it to a
format we understand,
and then the syncer
reads that format
and realizes the
changes on the cluster.
And then I mentioned that we
support hierarchical quota.
Well, again, inside
of Kubernetes
today there is no hierarchy.
It's just flat namespaces.
So we wrote our own
admission controller
which understands hierarchy and
can support oversubscription.
And so now when you
create pods and whatnot,
you actually can control
the number of CPUs
at a group of namespaces level.
So now I'm going to
talk a little bit more
about our sources of truth
that we shipped in the alpha.
So in the alpha,
we have Git and we
have GCP as a source of truth.
And so I'm going to
start talking about Git.
And the reason we chose Git,
is because GitOps turns out
to be a way that a
lot of organizations
think about managing policy.
And the advantages
here get to some
of the idea of the workflow
that John spoke about.
Code tooling, like Git, supports
the idea of pre-commits.
You can do continuous
integration.
You can do code reviews.
And so now you can think
of creating an RBAC
policy as a proposal
or a merge request,
and then someone
then can approve it,
and at once it gets integrated.
And then once it
gets integrated,
we automatically sync it down
to the cluster and apply it.
So this lets you use a
workflow and introduce
arbitrary levels of
policy and metapolicy
into your management.
So specifically with
the Git source of truth,
we've created our
own directory format
which represents the hierarchy.
And effectively, we
use the file system,
which is a very good, natural
way to represent hierarchy.
And you'll see here
in this example
on the right, where you
have Foo Corp, which is
the root of the organization.
And then underneath
it you have online,
and online's a department.
And within online, you can
have a series of namespaces,
and you also can have
an RBAC binding YAML.
And so, what we do is we use the
same YAML you use in kubectl.
So it's the same
exact type of thing
you'd write if you
were writing kubectl,
except you're checking
it into a repo.
And because it
has the hierarchy,
we'll actually take
those RBAC policies,
and we flatten them to create
the bindings in each namespace,
giving the online
admin the ability
to see shipping app backend,
and shipping prod, et cetera.
Now, what we also have is
the concept of a vetting tool
that makes sure that the
integrity of this file system
stays right.
So if you check in random
stuff-- for example,
if you create a directory
under a namespace--
that's not allowed.
So for us, what's really
important is the question of,
will it blend, or will it apply?
The answer should always be yes.
And every time that question
is asked, it's always yes.
So this is a really big
deal in policy as code,
because you don't
want to check things
in that get to the end
of the pipeline and fail.
Because when that
happens, you're
now stuck with a situation
where your Git source of truth
no longer represents the
reality on the clusters.
And then the
operator right there,
if they don't do anything,
that stays persistent.
And then you don't have a
good idea of what's what,
or you have to revert to change
and figure out what happens.
So we spent a bunch of time
creating a vetting tool that
makes sure that the integrity
of that tree is done,
and that's part of the alpha.
So anyways, once you commit,
this stuff is connected to
and grabbed each cluster,
and the policies are applied.
OK.
Now I want to talk about
our other source of truth,
which is GCP.
So within GCP there
is a hierarchy,
and it's defined through
the Cloud Resource Manager.
So the Cloud
Resource Manager has
the concept of an organization,
which is the root.
It has GCP folders, which are
basically sub organizations,
and projects.
Now, projects in GCP are the
minimum level of tenancy.
And namespaces in Kubernetes are
the minimum level of tenancy.
So they have a really nice
relationship one-to-one
with each other.
And so what we've done
here is we've said, OK,
with an API that
we're also putting out
with the alpha launch, you
can associate a namespace
with a project.
So now what happens is, is
that if you IM policies,
and you use Cloud for IM,
and you set it on a project,
and you associate that
project with a namespace,
we will synchronize the IM
policy to an RBAC policy
on the cluster.
So you can manage all of
your access control policies,
whether it be for
using Cloud SQL,
or whether it's using
Kubernetes, in the same place.
And this even works
whether you're
using GKE or using
Kubernetes on GCE,
or even using Amazon, or
another on-prem cloud provider.
You can use the GCP
hierarchy with IM
to manage those workloads.
And so what this
thing does is, one,
it converts IM policies to RBAC.
But also, it does
the compilation
using the GCP Cloud
Resource Manager
hierarchy to provide the
ability to do the subdivision
of namespace management.
So with that, I'm
going to take you
back to John who will do a
demonstration of what I just
talked about.
JOHN MURRAY: OK.
RAY COLLINE: Thanks, John.
JOHN MURRAY: Before
I get into the demo,
I just want to set the
stage a little bit.
So Ray showed you a Git
example a little bit earlier.
That's what I'm going
to walk through here,
and just kind of show you how
I define some namespaces, how
I set up tenants so
that they can deploy
their pods on the clusters.
We'll talk a little bit
about controlling quota,
particularly controlling
quota across namespaces.
And then we'll set up a new
namespace for a new tenant just
to show you what
that looks like.
We'll do it across a
couple of clusters.
The example we're going
to walk through here
is Foo Corp. Foo Corp
has, today, right now,
an online division,
and the online division
has dev, staging,
and prod set up
as namespaces on
all the clusters.
That's the policy file that
we'll be applying here.
And then we've got policies
attached at different levels
of the hierarchy here.
Up at the top we've
got admin policies
so that we can view the
pods, set pod security policy
across the entire organization.
And then down at the level
of the namespace tenants,
we'll define in name spaces
themselves, set up some shared
resource quota, as well
as namespace level quota,
and we'll set up
a pod creator role
so our dev team can show up
and do what they do best,
which is deploy applications.
Can we cut over to the demo?
OK, great.
So what you're seeing
here is a tmux session.
I've got a watch
on the right side.
That's a local repository,
or local version
of the repository.
It's actually hosted
on GitHub, and it
shows the basic
high level policies
that I've got applied
across my company right now.
So none of the namespace
structure is in there.
We don't need any namespaces
specific to our development.
I'm watching two clusters
here at the bottom,
just listing out the namespaces.
And that's just the basic stuff
that comes with Kubernetes,
as well as our agents
that are installed locally
on the clusters.
So let's get started.
I'm going to look
at this cluster
here on the left with kubectl.
And now I'm going to bring
in a bunch of policies.
So I'm just copying
these locally from one
directory to another
on my machine.
And you see from the
tree that now we're
going to add this online
division to Foo Corp.
Underneath online
there, you've got
shipping app backend,
which is our service, which
has three namespaces--
dev, prod, and staging.
All those have
namespace definitions,
so they're just standard YAML,
as well as some role binding.
So we've got the pod
creator role binding here.
And you notice that's at a
level above the namespaces.
So that pod creator role
binding will apply to all three
of those namespaces.
And the same is true
of the quota there.
So we'll be enforcing that quota
as a shared pool of resources
across the three namespaces.
And then we've got kind of
namespace level role bindings
here for job creator, and
a namespace level rule
defined there.
So that's the
initial policy state
that I want on my clusters.
I'm going to go ahead and make
a commit here up to GitHub
to initialize some of those
policies, and push it out.
OK, so that's going up to
the cloud, being applied.
And you can see there, locally,
cluster 1 picked it up,
and cluster 2 is a
couple of seconds behind,
but it also picked it up.
So what happened there is
the pods that we've installed
with our system on these
individual clusters
are constantly pulling
that repository,
pulling down the whole thing,
interpreting the hierarchy
there, flattening it out
into Kubernetes namespaces,
and making all the
policy applications.
So now I've got all of
my namespaces set up,
let's go take a look at it.
So if I look at one of
these role bindings--
and this is the pod
creator role binding here
that I've got set up at
an intermediate level
of the shipping app backend.
If I look at that definition,
it's pretty simple.
It's giving me a
pod creator a role,
which allows me to deploy
pods in the cluster.
And we're binding
that to our developer
here, Alice, at
Foo Corp. So that's
going to give Alice the ability
to do whatever she needs
to do to manage her application
across those three namespaces.
If you look at the actual
role bindings on the cluster,
you can see in shipping dev that
it's got three role bindings.
So this is the flattened
out version of the hierarchy
that we have in our repository.
It's got the Foo
Corp viewers, which
is up at the top, defined.
It's got a pod
creator role binding
that we were just talking about.
And it's got a
namespace-specific role binding
in job creators.
So that's what our system is
doing is flattening that out
and applying it to all the name
spaces across all the clusters.
And if we want to test that
out, we can pretend we're Alice
and try to get some
secrets out of Kubernetes.
Pod creator role binding
does not give me access
to those secrets,
and so that fails.
But if I try to get the
pods, that succeeds.
And now I don't have
any pods, but it
didn't fail the off-check.
So let's look at the quota.
This is the quota file that's
in shipping app backend.
So it's up there at
the intermediate level
of the hierarchy.
And this is a quota
definition that
is shared by these
three namespaces.
It's a pretty
simple quota YAML--
three pods, one core,
and one gig of memory.
So let's test that.
I'm going to create a pod
here with my exciting new
application BusyBox Sleep, and
I'm going to ask for about 80%
of a processor.
So that goes
through, no problem.
It's less than the shared quota.
And now I'm eating
up 80% of that shared
quota with a deployment in
the namespace shipping prod.
So what happens if I want to
deploy in one of the sister
namespaces here, shipping dev?
Same image, but now I'm
going to ask for 30%.
So I asked for 80% before,
I'm asking for 30% now.
For those of you who haven't
been able to do the math,
that's more than one CPU,
and so this should fail.
And it does.
And what's happening
here is we're
evaluating the quota
at the shipping dev
level, which passes.
And then we're going up
a level in the hierarchy
and serially evaluating
the quota that's
shared across all three
of these namespaces,
and that's where this fails.
And so, you can set quota in
the hierarchy at an arbitrary
number of levels here, and
we'll enforce it up the chain.
And we think this is a pretty
cool way to deal with the fact
that Kubernetes only
natively manages resource
quota at the namespace level.
If you have sub t
namespace, but you
don't want to deal with
portioning out pools of quota
across them, this is one
way you can accomplish that.
And just to show you that
it does actually work,
we'll try the same
application here,
but we'll ask for only 10%.
And that goes through.
So that's quota.
Let's set up a new namespace.
So let's say we've
got a new dev team who
wants to come on to the
Kubernetes deployments
that we've got, and they want
a home on all of our clusters.
That's fairly simple here.
All I have to do is
make them a directory
and define them a namespace.
So I'm going to make
a directory locally,
which you should see
pop into my tree here.
So this is shipping
app front-end,
and we'll give the
front-end team a home.
Now, that's an empty
directory, so I've
got to give them a
namespace definition.
And we'll just set up a simple
namespace for them in YAML.
So I've got my directory.
I've got my YAML.
And I'm going to commit that
and push it up the cloud.
And if you're looking at the
bottom there at my clusters,
they should pick up that change.
And you'll see the shipping
app front-end namespace there.
Six seconds, five seconds--
just showing up on the clusters.
The great thing about this is
I'm only running two clusters
here, but because all the
clusters are pulling down this,
you can run this system
with one central repository.
And as long as that
repository can handle the QPS,
you can scale this out to as
many clusters as you want.
So let's take a look at
some of these role bindings
for shipping app front-end.
So you can see it's got
a flattened out role
binding from Foo Corp viewers.
That's fine, but
it's not going to let
anybody on the development
team do anything.
So we need to set up a
role binding for Alice,
our developer, so
that she can get
into the front-end namespace
and start deploying some
of our front-end applications.
So the way I'm going to do
that is not to go and define
a separate role
binding for Alice,
because she's already got a
role binding for pod creation.
What I'm going to do is take
the existing role binding--
so that's the one that's
shipping app backend here,
this pod creator role binding--
and I'm just going to move that
up a level in the hierarchy.
So I'm going to take that
binding and just say,
OK, actually, Alice should have
pod creation across everything
below online in my tree.
And so if I just move
that up one directory
by moving the file
around, that should
be sufficient to give Alice
the privileges that she needs.
So I'll push that change.
And then if I go look
at the role bindings
on shipping app front-end,
I should see, hopefully,
Alice's new permission pop in.
And there it is-- four seconds
ago, online pod creators.
And so just by moving
that role abiding around
in my repository, now it
applies to a whole different set
of namespaces and my
developers are good to go.
Alice can go and
do what she needs
to do in terms of deployment.
So that's the basics of this.
You see the quota can be managed
across different hierarchies.
You can see a sane way to
define things once and do it
in a way that fits the
hierarchy of larger teams.
And doing things
in the Git way here
really allows you to do
the GitOps experience
of making these commits,
validating them, potentially
doing a pull request and a
review, and kind of sanely
checking that
across team members
to make sure that
everybody's happy with them
before they're applied and
pulled down to the clusters.
And then you're
only doing it once.
And because the automation
that's available here,
as well as some of the
monitoring and logging that we
have that lets you know that
changes actually get propagate,
you only have to do it once.
And if you have made
a mistake, if you
did apply some policies that
are problematic for you,
all you have to do is roll back.
We've got the full
history here, because it's
in a code repository, so I
can revert all those changes
that I made, roll them back,
and push that up to the cloud.
And I'm back where I started.
It'll kill all of my
namespaces because they're
managed by [? Nomos, ?] get
rid of all those deployments,
and put me back into a state
that allows me to roll back
to an earlier, vetted version
of my central policy management.
And so that's our demo.
Can we switch back
to the slides?
So that's basically what
we've got for you guys today.
The alpha is now open
for participation.
If you're interested
in participating,
that's the link there.
QR code will take
you to the same place
if you take a picture
of it with your phone.
There's just a brief form there.
We're trying to bring as
many people in as we can.
So fill that out, let us
know if you're interested.
OK, well, thanks a lot
for joining us, guys.
RAY COLLINE: Thank
you very much.
JOHN MURRAY: We'll be around.
And have a great conference.
[MUSIC PLAYING]